madame monsieur merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france virginie joron
vous n'êtes pas en faveur de ce pas ça
ni terres ni de la vaccination
obligatoire
le gouvernement aurait donc dû selon
vous continuez à convaincre sans passer
par la contrainte
comment faire déjà je constate que le
quinquennat ma de macron a commencé par
des manifestations et finit aussi par
d'autres manifestations
donc effectivement le past and i terre
on l'a bien vu et on le voit encore
aujourd'hui est une atteinte aux
libertés individuelles donc oui nous
sommes content parce que nous
considérons depuis le départ que se
passe et doit être fait d'une manière
volontaire et pas contraignante
mg on voit que petit à petit comme nous
on nous avait vendu un vaccin non
obligatoire celui ci nous pousse à nous
faire vacciner en plus il a été imposé
lors des vacances des vacances une tour
n'a été pris de court pour se mettre
comment dire en règle et du coup on se
retrouve maintenant certains coincé
d'autres aussi et c'est très important
de le dire aujourd'hui manifestent et
ils sont vaccinés
parce que ce pass sanitaire va
effectivement aller vers une ségrégation
est aussi un point très important c'est
le secret médical
on va à l'encontre de ce principe
fondamental qui est le secret médical
donc effectivement il fallait trouver
d'autres solutions nous allons composer
plusieurs 1 notamment le développement
des traitements anti co-lead développer
les autotests continue d'appliquer les
gestes barrière mais sans entrer dans
cette contrainte et forcée à devoir
montrer que nous sommes en bonne santé
et surtout qu'en plus il ya des failles
aujourd'hui dans ce pas ça ni terre
aujourd'hui certificat comme quoi on a
eu qu'ovide ne peut pas être intrigué
ans se passe sanitaire donc tout a été
fait dans la précipitation et
aujourd'hui j'entends et je comprends
ces manifestants française parlant vous
êtes président de la confédération des
commerçants
vous êtes en faveur de ce pass
sanitaires pourquoi selon vous est il
nécessaire aujourd'hui en france eh bien
écoutez il faut rester d'abord dans
l'objectivité
il faut rester dans la mesure et il faut
rester dans le bon sens avec plus de
22000 4 surgissent à nouveau pour ne
peut pas rester insensible parce que moi
tout ce qui se dit j'oppose un argument
je souhaite conserver la liberté sur le
long terme et d'une manière définitive
de consommer de sortie de partir en
vacances d'aller dans les magasins
et si un quatrième confinement sur
données madame ce serait très grave pour
l'état d'esprit de nos citoyens ce
serait très grave
sur un plan économique et l'aveu insiste
lourdement que représentent des
commerçants indépendants 450 milles
ce sont des petites entreprises elles
sont si fragiles parfois même que les
autres qui est si d'aventuré on était à
nouveau conflit né ce serait pas mal
alors bien évidemment personnellement je
ne suis pas en faveur de l'obligation
généralisées systématiques de la
vaccination
malgré ce n'est pas psy qui paie un
communiqué de presse nationale avec le
conseil du commerce de france nos
collègues puis sortent les très très
grosse entreprise et nous avons dit à la
population nous avons insisté nous avons
lourdement dit dac ciné vous vacciner
vaccinons nous donc voyez je reste dans
la mesure d'une part il faut aussi être
réaliste le président de la république à
ce jour
à part le problème des soignants est un
peu particulier n'a pas décidé
l'obligation de se vacciner c'est quand
même important quand on veut aller dans
une manifestation
on peut effectuer un test pcr ou
antigénique et on est amis donc le pass
sanitaire ce n'est pas que être vaccinés
c'est également
à prouver que l'on n'est pas malade et à
ce moment là
bien sûr on peut attaquer à ses
occupations
donc vous voyez mon discours il est
mesuré
il est il comprend la revendication
parce que la revendication c'est une adn
il faut qu'elle soit réservée manifesté
cet endroit et il faut mais il
il faut aussi rester dans une mesure
manifester sur des choses qui ne sont
pas acceptables
on a entendu des mots fracture
en fait on a entendu des mots à brac à
l'avant dans les manifestations et ça ce
n'est pas bien mais voila voila ma
position je souhaite que l'économie
continue que le plan de relance semaine
à exécution pleinement et que bien sûr
nous soyons vigilants sur le sanitaire
parce qu'il y va de nos vies de notre
vie virginie devront nous sommes dans la
quatrième vague avec un invariant delta
très virulent peut-être un autre
variante qui pourrait émerger dans
quelques mois et le gouvernement
présente la vaccination est donc le pass
and it erp comme la seule arme pour
lutter contre cette épidémie
justement qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez quand il vous dit cela continue
ce que le pass and i ter la vaccination
est la seule arme aujourd'hui le pass
sanitaire permet juste de se déplacer ou
pas là en l'occurrence à va restreindre
nos libertés de travail et d'accéder à
des commerces
donc c'est plutôt sale passe sanitaires
et c'est vrai que dans ce pas ça ni
terry il ya l'obligation enfin il ya le
certificat vaccinale où effectivement
est intégrer cette notion vaccin le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que on le
voit dans un pays comme aujourd'hui en
islande les vaccins n'ont pas tous
aujourd'hui une efficacité à 100% donc
je vais bien je l'entends cette
obligation vaccinale mais déjà
aujourd'hui
et moi je n'ai vu au niveau européen il
ya un problème de transparence d'accès
au contrat aujourd'hui on peut quand
même se poser la question d'efficacité
des vaccins qu'elle quel laboratoire
choisir en priorité parce que là aussi
selon le médecin on a une fois moderne à
une fois kaiser
johnson donc là aussi c'est assez flou
pour demain évidemment et d'autres
experts et je laisse plutôt la parole
les experts en ce sens dire qu'il y aura
d'autres variantes donc effectivement
prendre à s'adapter comme je les dis aux
prêts à un préambule il ya d'autres
solutions développées les traitements je
vois qu'aujourd'hui en israël ils ont
trouvé trois nouveaux traitements dont
il faut il faut développer il faut
continuer cette recherche et il faut
aussi trouver et mettre en place par
exemple l'autre les autotests et encore
une fois faire confiance au citoyen
français
quand on est malade quand on a dream on
reste à la maison donc je pense qu'il
faut arrêter d'infantiliser les français
j'entends monsieur aussi la raison
concernant confinement effectivement ce
n'est pas envisageable et je ne pense
pas que le gouvernement aille dans ce
sens et toute façon je pense que la
population française n'a pas n'a pas
envie d'y aller mais plus donc voilà il
ya des des solutions diverses et variées
je crois qu'il faut pas tout axer sur le
vaccin
il ya les gestes barrière a continué il
ya effectivement la recherche et le
développement des traitements en
parallèle et je vois que des pays sont
sur ce point assez avancé et je crois
qu'il faut aller dans ce sens français
panon bi voudrait juste voir avec vous
la justification de ligue et veyran de
la commission des lois du sénat
il a dit nous avons deux fois réussir le
passe vite très vite où nous exposer au
risque de devoir re confiné notre pays
la confédération que vous représentez
les petits commerçants
est ce qu'il pourrait survivre un
nouveau confinement justement justement
et après les propos de madame députée
européenne six ans et je dois dire que
dans l'application des mesures à la
suite des propos du président de la
république il ya des mesures qui nous
inquiète je suis représentant 2 du
secteur de la restauration entre autres
fils des bars je vous assure
dans la mise en application il ya des
trous dans la raquette
parce que
demandez le pass sanitaires sur les
terrasses des cafés des restaurants en
plein été je ne pense pas que ce soit
souhaitable empêcher demandé le tass
sanitaires pour accéder aux centres
commerciaux
je trouve que ce n'est vraiment pas
d'aspérités et ce n'est pas une bonne
mesure
donc je redis les centres commerciaux
ont été fermés pendant des mois
vous voulez leur dire maintenant que il
faut continuer à réduire leurs activités
à perturber leur chiffre d'affaires non
ce n'est pas souhaitable
alors il y à la vaccination il ya la
prise de conscience sanitaire je pense
que je m'en suis expliquée dans la
précédente phase mais pour autant dans
les mesures d'application
moi je ne veux plus entendre parler de
sanctions dire un restaurateur ne serait
affublé de 45000 euros d'amendé
ça c'est inadmissible sanaa ça n'a pas
lieu d'être
il faut faire davantage de pédagogie de
la part du gouvernement mais sur le plan
sanitaire
on ne rassurait pas une population par
en énonçant des mesures des sanctions
terrible vis-à-vis des citoyens
vis-à-vis des commerçants donc là à ce
niveau là c'est vrai madame vous avez
raison
si à nouveau le confinement sur le nez
il ya des entreprises qui risquerait de
disparaître et notamment celle que je
représente les plus petits merci francis
palombes d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes président de
la confédération des commerçants virgin
jauron merci à vous je rappelle que vous
êtes eurodéputés du rassemblement
national
merci a dit